[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking of uh appealing
mike florio pro football talk live coho
see mike that's how you get nominated
for a sports emmy
segway like that not win one but get
nominated
well that's good and uh yeah hey you
know on what you were just saying dan
this issue comes up all the time
i just wish they would have one rule
that applies
to all service academies and stick with
it
because it seems like every year it's a
different twist they're allowed to
they're not allowed to i mean if i'm
army or air force
this is a great recruiting poster for me
hey come to
come to this service academy we'll let
you
potentially play in the nfl unless of
course we change our mind four years
from now which is possible so maybe we
won't mention that
they just need to have one rule needs to
be the same needs to be fair to these
guys
then you know going in am i going to
have the chance or not have the chance
if my football career works out
i think every roster should have one
extra roster spot
for a military graduate
i i can get behind that i guess i don't
know
i guess well you're un-american if
you're not going to get behind that mic
[Laughter]
mike florio un-american wow
i i just look
there there was once a time when the
best football players ended up at the
service academy yeah but
the world has changed so much the the
sport
of pro football has changed so much the
way it works out is the best of the best
end up at alabama clemson or ohio state
and everybody else is just trying to get
whatever scraps they can find so
i i look it would not be
something that contradicts the overt
efforts by the nfl to cater to the
military so it wouldn't surprise me if
the nfl did
all right let's get to the serious stuff
here it feels like there's some jedi
mind games being played
by the packers and aaron rodgers or
certainly aaron rodgers here
and i want you to paraphrase what you
put on pro football talk
because if i don't know if aaron rodgers
is like
i'm not going to be painted as a bad guy
where the packers are trying to paint
him as a bad guy
okay what hap what like what's the end
result with all of this
mike it's whatever aaron rodgers wants
it to be and i think
whatever happens he's going to act like
it's what he wanted so i think that's
one of the reasons why he's not telling
anybody
what he really wants but when he talks
to guys like james jones
who he knows will turn around and appear
on radio and tv
and say what he's allowed to say what
aaron rodgers
authorizes him to say and james jones
says
the situation is fixable i think aaron
rodgers
wants packers fans to say to the packers
why haven't you fixed it aaron says it's
fixable why haven't you fixed it
and when mark murphy the team ceo
not even in response to a question about
aaron rodgers just kind of gratuitously
in a written column where he had a
chance to write it and read it and read
it be sure it's what he wanted to say
says that this situation is dividing our
fan base that's his way
of letting rogers know your worst case
scenario
of becoming a pariah among packers fans
is coming to fruition
so it is high level pr games being
played between these two sides
rogers wants the packers to be to blame
the packers want rogers to be to blame
and if he just doesn't show up for
training camp i'd say most fans
of the team because they always fall in
line behind the laundry
most fans of the team are going to say
you're under contract you should be here
yeah i'm just trying to understand at
what point does aaron rodgers say
now if i'm going to a new team i better
get there soon
and if the packers realize he doesn't
want to be there then when do you move
on
and what do you get and are you
comfortable with jordan love being your
starter
like the clock is ticking here mike for
both of these sides
and who's going to blink first you know
dan i've said a couple of times over the
past week or two it's better for the
packers at this point
to go ahead and wait until after the
season to trading because if you trade
them now
you're getting 20 22 picks anyway go
ahead and wait until you get 10 teams at
the table
now you would have gotten more for them
if you had traded them in march but now
you got the broncos and maybe the
raiders showing up for this
auction you get to march after teams
have had a chance
to roll the dice one more year with
their current quarterbacks and decide
man this guy sucks we got to find
somebody better
you're going to have teams lining up for
a chance to get aaron rodgers
so if i'm the packers i think he chooses
not to play
we get 30 million back or more between
the salary we don't pay him
bonus money we can recoup we don't have
to worry about him going somewhere else
and making us look like idiots this year
we get a chance to let jordan love get
ready and maybe the fans will understand
that aaron put us in a tough spot where
we had to throw him into the fire before
he was ready
and and we trade him for more next year
and we'll know after a year of jordan
love whether or not he really is the guy
you know at some point they need to find
out
is he the guy they used a first round
pick on him they see something in him
that makes them think he can be the guy
so i really do think you attach mark
murphy to a lie detector test
i think he would prefer that rogers not
show up this year
i love the pr machine of now promoting
jordan love
that you had dan orlovsky of espn former
nfl quarterback who basically came out
and said
guy can't play jordan love and then the
next day
you had reporters covering the packers
who of course
are sort of beholden to the packers like
hey jordan love
man do you see some of those passes
those throws he had there
i don't know how good he is and i don't
know when we find out until there's live
bullets here mike i don't care what you
do in
shorts and nobody gets to hit you and
you threw a 35 yard out
i want to know what happens when you
have to process all this in real time
and it's two phases it's live bullets
plus what happens after four to six
weeks of you
playing and defenses can break down film
and figure out how to stop you
can you and your coaches counter that
sims had a great point yesterday on pft
live
and he's been involved in situations
breaking news
chris sims had a really good time it's
worth pointing out because it's so rare
but he's seen this before where the
coaching staff wants to build confidence
so dan
is it really crazy to think that after
jordan love looks so
bad on tuesday matt leflore gets
together
with joe berry the defensive coordinator
and they script
the plays we're going to call the
defenses that are going to be used
so the play pops and it gives jordan
love a chance when the reporters are
watching
wow create these tweets this isn't the
reporters
lying this is the packers deliberately
engineering a scenario
where jordan love has guys wide open or
wide ass open as bruce arians would say
and and you you get a positive they got
look they owe it to jordan love to help
this guy out
he didn't ask for this do you think he
would have voluntarily signed up
for the packers if he had his druthers
in april of 2020
hell no so they got to take care of this
guy you don't want to ruin him
because he's caught in the crossfire
between rogers in the front office
he's mike florio co-host of pro football
talk live
you'll see that on nbc sports network
and also here on peacock with chris sims
the buccaneers off season uh i guess
went as well as possible
where they didn't need to add much they
just resign people and then tom brady
i guess is going to be a new quarterback
a different quarterback after this knee
surgery he said he was
a he's going to be able to do some
things he couldn't have done last year
i don't know if anybody followed up by
saying what exactly is that tom
that you'll be able to do so what do you
make of uh
tom's revelation that he's going to be
able to do some different things
he's going to run a 529 instead of a
5-3-1 wow
hey he admitted the other day and they
need to get him to quit talking about
this this is how the jets got in trouble
back in 2009 when brett favre went to
the vikings and he kept making excuses
for why they
fell apart down the stretch and he
started talking about his arm injury
eventually the nfl fined everyone from
the jets for hiding it on the injury
report
you got brady saying his knee was
injured back in april or may of last
year he had pretty serious surgery as he
described it he was never listed
on any buccaneers injury report with a
knee injury at some point
with with gambling spreading and the
league's got to be concerned about these
things and i know it's
you know most fans like who cares well
gamblers care in the league should care
because
eventually the bucks are going to get in
trouble but you know dan another thing
sims and i were talking about this week
if the packers are just able to complete
that comeback when they're down 28 to 10
they've got fourth and whatever it was
inside the 10. if they would have won
that game
think of how different the vibe would
have been around the buccaneers
from that point until now tom brady
meltdown
interceptions on three straight drives
they blow an 18 point lead
maybe a lot of those guys who resigned
go elsewhere it's amazing how much
that one moment affected the packers in
a negative way
and boosted the buccaneers of this team
where we're saying who who's there
who's their competitor in the nfc who do
they have to worry about
really they got a path to the super bowl
again
and it could have gone so differently if
that game in green bay had ended a
different way
well look at kansas city with patrick
mahomes we would be questioning if he
could win the big game
if san francisco doesn't forget about
tyreke hill
or you know they don't have a couple of
stops or garoppolo doesn't overthrow
like it these things are it's so small
two more first downs jimmy garoppolo is
viewed differently
and patrick mahomes we would say well i
can't win the big one
matt ryan you get another first down you
kick a field goal
he's an automatic hall of famer there
like it's so small these margins
all of these how many super bowls did
brady win needing help from somebody
else
but tom is the goat because bina terry
did this
or rodney harrison did this you know
pretty it's it's pretty remarkable david
tyree doesn't catch that ball
is is eli manning a hall of famer with
one super bowl
and you could probably say maybe not
even though he did it in new york
hey if mario manningham doesn't catch
that ball at the sideline in super bowl
46 if wes welker catches a pass that
really wasn't
thrown as accurately as people would say
from brady
the patriots win that one and there goes
another one for the giants it it's
amazing how much
work and effort and sweat and toil and
study and time it all goes into
to get yourself in a spot where that one
thing goes your way yeah
months and months and months to get to
that one moment per year
when it all falls your way and it just
shows you how hard it is in today's nfl
that's why no one's
repeated since 2003 2004 eight times
in the first 39 super bowls teams went
back to back
and it hasn't happened since because
they're all packed together and it comes
down
to those those moments that are there
and then they're gone
should we celebrate we have lost the uh
sports emmy best studio host four years
in a row so we
we are the buffalo bills now now they're
viewed as losers
should we view ourselves as losers
no no because you've been nominated
but we lost i well well it's still been
nominated
that's more than pft live can say that's
more than i can say
so you're you're nominated yeah but we
don't measure ourselves with your show i
mean
i mean it's like the old west virginia
penn state robbery
it was a big deal for us what a big deal
for penn state but anyway
you're nominated you're there you're in
the conversation all right thank you
mike
have a great weekend no offense all
right thank you mike that's mike mike
floyd
pro football talk live co-host